finished
ladies and gentlemen welcome to you
sanaa a prime minister sheikh hasina
the prime minister of new zealand
madam g sinndar last months even
just co chaired the
christchurch call meeting for
the elimination of terrorism
and violent extremism in  line exactly
two months after the
terrorist attacks against the
muslim community of christchurch
the heads of state and government of
jordan senegal indonesia
norway canada the united kingdom
of ireland
the president of the european commission
joined us  for a
working meeting with representatives
of internet companies and civil society
companies twitter
microsoft google yahoo youtube facebook
dailymotion amazon account was
represented at the highest level as well
as the wikimedia foundation and the new
zealand and french civil societies
of  the internet beyond the
present several other companies and
governments have  t have already expressed
their support for this initiative,
we all experienced two months ago,
particularly in our country
which had to experience the pain of terrorist attacks,
what you may have felt,
but you have decided, Madam Prime
Minister, to  react by not acting and
that is why I proposed to you a few weeks ago that we be
able to join
efforts and that the initiative that you
had started to take to fight
against online terrorism
could join the take for
good initiative  launched last year by
france so that we can
act together and what gave rise to this call
this call to action
and in this period when we are
also mourning the easter attacks
in sri lanka and our  soldiers
on the front line in the fight
against terrorism
a few days ago
our objective was simple that what
happened in each of these places
would never happen again or what
happened  in christchurch it is not
only an abject terrorist attack
it is the transformation
once again of the internet into a
mad propaganda machine at the service of the
fracture of our societies of the war of
all against all an objective sought
by the  far-right terrorists as well
as by Islamist terrorists,
we have been involved in this fight for a long time
and we had
the opportunity this afternoon to
recall that a Franco-
British action plan was launched in June
2010 following the
large-scale attacks  -britain right
here a work of the global internet
counter terrorism forums was
then conducted the paris call
for trust and security in
cyberspace brought together 70 states and 300
organizations text strong taste of last year
had begun to address  these
subjects a European directive in
2018 was issued precisely to allow the
removal of terrorist content
online and we are continuing this work  at
the French and European level in
particular with new actions,
but the objective of our
joint initiative and of this call that the lady the
Prime Minister presented in a
few moments was on the one hand
to widen the field of mobilization
we had around  of us all the
continents that were present
I mentioned senegal indonesia
canada beyond the already
mentioned europeans and therefore for the first time
the governments of the whole world
were gathered at this level with
this force then it is  an
approach bringing together
governments, civil societies
and internet players is therefore
fully inclusive and above all it is
an approach that will be followed with the
concrete effects that we expect from
everyone there will be a technical follow-up from
the month  june in aqaba initiative taken
several months ago by the king of
jordan who were with us we
will then meet again and our members
secretariat comm  one of this initiative
with all the actors
there will be the meeting of biarritz and
the g7 where we precisely wish to
adopt a charter for a field of an
open and non-violent internet and we
will meet on this format there
I  I still hope to be expanded to make a
first point on concrete actions
in September in New York on the sidelines of the
United Nations so we decided
to act and I must say that beyond
this action I was very happy
Madam  the prime minister once
again to welcome you to paris after
your spring 2018 visit and to tell you
that beyond the pain that we have
shared with you and your people,
it is also the joy of meeting you and
the will to act with  strength together
that's why it was very proud and
very happy to welcome you today
in may 2009 against new technology at the end
of maccabi haifa fc
leeds max
thank you very much
answer that of facebook marc
zuckerberg was indeed present  in
paris the week
we had a long exchange and
facebook was at the heart of
many difficulties related to these
subjects we saw it and we
spoke about it very clearly also for the
different facebook modalities which may
have been used by or  terrorists
in the context of attacks by
hostage takers france had to experience
the very specific case fortunately there were no
victims but
taking hostage to use the live facilities
for precisely given to see mark
zuckerberg d  'abord has committed with his
company to a real
innovative cooperation with the French government
within the framework of this smart tv the
channels that we wanted, that is to
say that he authorized the teams of the
French regulator to come to
the  of the machine share
the most confidential information
to see how we could in order to
fight against the sons of terrorism is
also a kind of content and the
unique methods of harassment  which sometimes
can give rise to the use of
facebook is well how we could
better regulate and we are moreover going to
translate the fruits of this exchange enough
of this intelligent regulation within the
framework of a text of law which is in the process
of  be prepared by the parliamentarian
so there is work in progress
he could not be with us
today for very personal reasons
he had been with nick clegg ex were
present around the table with a long
exchange and facebook  is engaged in
a procedure there also of cooperation
with the governments to deprive the
users of facebook of the facilities
precisely of the live
when the latter are identified as
being dangerous or by the platform
on the one hand and the brand a
real advance by  compared to what we
know and that we still have to
go further and the call to strike on
in this direction but believe that we
would be unfair with fez or if we
let  s to say that they were either
indifferent or uncooperative then
also this spirit then
on the American administration first of all
I see the progress that has been made
since the summer of 2010 is I was talking about
the Franco-British prison initiative
June 2017
i remember a g7 that followed
we did not manage to have a
common position and the
presence of prime minister
trudeau in particular with steam is a strong element
that shows that in the
north american world where as you know
freedom of expression is a very
strong value is essential
well we recognize that it is important
while protecting it to move towards
more regulation of the internet to what we
must create a public order of the internet
which allows the free expression of ideas
but also a better regulation of
content especially when they
seize terrorism and the presence of
minister trudeau in the period
canada is a few months away
from elect  ion marks his
personal commitment commitment of his country
it was very important for us and it
shows that the world also die
American who is moving
then the American administration
expressed itself to say that it
supported the objectives  that she would do
everything to cooperate
she has not formally endorsed
the call for creation at this stage but we
will do everything so that there can be
a concrete commitment I
would say more formal but I consider
that the progress has already been made  fact that
the American administration is
considered important during a meeting,
that is to say that it
shares objectives and the will is
a completely possible element in the
corner of the call of christchurch and the
commitments made are different from the
previous commitments the spread
continues to 4 and of which three months in
specifically what will be
changed for digital actors be
careful then to start in
a very concrete way  And
it calls for cry on different in
that also leave as I say all
the actors of the internet who are
precisely co responsible for the
implementation of what we have today to
decide then its commitments
are part of the  context, as
I say, exchanges have continued for two
years with the private sector of
the Internet and with heads of state
and government, but what we
wanted to do is go further and
the ambition of  call that we
launched together allows on the one hand to be
more precise with clear commitments
to remove terrorist content
online to allow to broaden what we
have decided mi which was strictly
European within the framework of the directive
and that  'he has ah if I can say access
in any case a
much wider geographical perimeter since one q as
I said new zealand
senegal indonesia canada then because
like a fiction a common framework for
in  frame the action
of Internet operators in the fight against
terrorist content have
themselves committed I have just given an
example for facebook to concrete actions
to support peace and
therefore the call today  7 1 an
extension of what has been
done geographically
in recent years what we have
done in europe and 1 now very
widely and we do it in a broader way
and then in terms of method we
associate the actors of the  internet
free foundations and civil society
and behind it we have a follow-up in
technical and political terms of this action
that's why I detail is in
my introductory remarks on the basis of
this call the leaders the citeaux of the
companies present with  our
technical teams will meet in aqaba
we have to see how to implement it
very concretely typically how we
ensure cooperative processes so
that all the governments that  have signed
crafter's appeal can as soon as possible
alert the a platform on an
individual who is estimated to have
precedents that he is dangerous what
type of commitment the platform makes
how it implements it
concretely we will have questions
as concrete and technical as what is
beyond the totality of
a terrorist nature and the commitments
in terms of speed of withdrawal from the
platforms and how do we
prevent this content from being viralized td
examine very technical deadlines
that we  had this afternoon where we walk
from our of our exchange but you
can ask for a platform to
withdraw all the terrorist councils where
they can be seen as
terrorist with marc times this gray area
the argument that he opposes us there is
another way also to
ask them to withdraw in their faith
so far from a work and our
way of doing and to ask them
to act on the contents which like  nce to
become a virus and therefore to have a
much stronger action than at that time
so now on the page this call
what we are going to define in this forum
are 20 the technical conditions
to put it back and there will be  in
September
an appointment which we will do two
things we will list the
concrete actions that have been taken on the basis
of today's call
mr we intend to withdraw them on the basis
of the commitments made today and we
will try  to widen the circle of
companies and countries that
join this agreement so the main
changes I see are
the geographical expansion
the intensity of the relationship, including on
a technical level, with
internet companies  and above all a
monitoring device because we decided
with the first mini is good to
set up a permanent secretariat
together to make the sacrifice
we will work very closely with
the Jordanians who launched the
trial  ssus of aqaba with the
united nations to see you doing the technical and political follow-up
on the ground continued
this direct contact alone with adjustments to
return to the right corner written what
was said today could prevent
and not that of a  Apart from the Prime
Minister,
the commitment made by facebook in
a clear manner, given his
terrorist characteristics, would have
led to him not being allowed
to use the facility,
but I believe that what needs to be
seen very clearly  in relation to
what in advance of the contents the
terrorists
the commitment made by the companies
today that they were there around
the table it is an immediate and permanent withdrawal
the commitment made we are going to expand
by facebook that  he would have touched on the
specific case is to better regulate live
streaming and to get out of this facility
sensitive audiences, including seven
people, that's what we're doing on the
actual costs of terrori  stes
and individuals is defined as
sensitive and then there is a whole other
continent thil is the hateful content
or what can lead to this action
what is this much more complex gray area
that we are
working on
alas the forum  that we have created will
allow us to move forward this is the whole
discussion that I mentioned
earlier and that we have already had with facebook, that is to
say cynically to this person she
was led so far  and besides that
and the watches and because she had had
access online to
racist content which may be the
case for racist anti-Semitic content
and not taking it will pay for
Islamist terrorism
therefore all forms of hateful content
which  can lead to an act of terrorism
even if they are not defined as a
theory it is on this subject that we must
move forward on intelligent regulation
because on this subject the
platforms rightly tell us that
you cannot  prohibiting it from us is
not terroristic and therefore it is this gray area
first of all what are we
prohibited from doing in each of our countries
by law and then there is a
new case of cooperation with the
platforms to allow on the one hand to
define the responsibilities of the
platforms when it conveys or make
respond to such discourse of m then
there is to define the modes of cooperation
these platforms must have with the
governments,
that is to say typically when we have
defined the characteristics in our
laws on the legal level and ensure
that the platforms cooperate very
quickly removes its content and
allows us to identify those who
distribute
it what in terms of prevention
compared to what you have experienced
would have  allowed I also think to have
the president madam prime minister
the european regulation being
discussed in brussels asks the
platforms to withdraw safe meters
and the terr  orisme under a marriage
an hour the correction call talks
about a game of a modesty withdrawal what
deadlines
and how to lille in order to be
able to question her and I want to add to the
last questions and if she had
four to ten in my column  a month
an alert to arrive there which quotes madam
angela merkel which recognizes having a
conflictual relationship with you in
an interview what can you
comment
then on the first point I would like to
be very precise because I know the
complexity of  this subject the
European directive it talks about it it's a bit like
this golden hour for terrorist orders
because there is this
gray area on hateful content what
I was talking about we are going to be defined in
the law
its  proposed law called avia and it
can then lead to a whole work
of regulation and sharing so it
's terrorist content because there the
definition is clear it's strict
it's
sincerely firm when we ret  ire in
the eure where immediately we are almost
at the same thing it's simply 7
we must not make a distinction on
this there is none we are on the same
objective the same firmness this is where
the  call for cry surge, as I was saying,
makes it possible to broaden what was decided to
leave within the framework of the
European directive to other geographies
and other countries, but beyond that
the call for spitters makes it possible to  put in
place a methodology of cooperation
with which the actors of the Internet and
the civil societies
where a directive is normal says the
right and the law which us our goal it is
indeed beyond the terrorist contents
as envisaged  by the
European directive to reinforce this by being
much stricter on their
hateful treatment which can therefore lead to
terrorism and more broadly to
violence in society and therefore horizon
a hater who is as I said
racist anti-Semites lead to the spo to
terrorism  give the  in the same way as
harassment on the internet
all this space that we
now want to regulate better this is what we
will do in terms of rights before we
can progress in
european law turn this
international cooperation then chancellor
merkel in her interview
that  said the same thing as what I said
a few meters from here when talking about a
fruitful confrontation
she said we work together
permanently we find compromises
we try to build them but there is
discussion you
know in a  relationship in particular
between france and germany
what are the options via the
sterile confrontation scenario
we don't agree we can't
go beyond our disagreements that we've
experienced this in the past  it can lead
to the worst either impotence or
war there is another scenario such a
sterile agreement that is to say we
only want to say or let say
build opinions which can be in
disagreement  rd that we no longer decide anything that
too we have known in the past
no we hold useless press conferences
and we leave Europe without
sleeping because we do not want to
disagree on anything or at the
sterile confrontation target to hear
this ground I believe the dispute
counters d'aguëro proposes shame is the
partner and we try together to
build a compromise we proposed at
the sorbonne in the fall of 2010 is a
new vision of europe  saying
it's terrible france and only six
months before the interests of france
offers us nothing we worked
for months in this confrontation so
that we arrived at the rope but this berg
the besseberg rope that is not the
totality of the Sorbonne project, but
it has made it possible to advance many
things and to find through this
fruitful confrontation a
Franco-German breakthrough which then
allows Europe to move forward
last week we proposed
with the Netherlands a  n ambitious text on
the climate which will therefore
what the Prime Minister
passed in all countries carbon neutrality
we managed to bring together nine countries nine
member states even a lot I said
it's terrible germany is not
with  you confrontation you did not
get there there is always germany
has joined us
around this text is of this
climatic ambition confrontation we are moving forward and
so here
we are we must succeed in accepting
momentary disagreements accept not
to be in total agreement  especially
to have the courage to affirm what
we want what is expected of
france in europe is to
clearly say what it wants what it
carries what are its ambitions and
then to build a compromise with
the  germany to be able to move forward,
that's the heart of our relationship and
that's how we have moved forward on
many things and that we will
continue to do so with the same
spirit of construction and the future  who
inspires us chancellor merkel